you got to stand
up I know my sister somewhere in the
world someday we going to meet
again keep your head held high just like
mom taught us it's time I be free from
you and then turn into creation I died
before I let that happen good that's
just a going away present I've been
the what was it that you wanted to bring
to this version of The Color Purple it
was very clear uh X years ago uh talking
to Oprah Winfrey that that there is so
much going on in the world that the the
story of Alice Walker that she's blessed
us with this of
perseverance and moving forward in life
and finding your voice and being seen
was still important for the world to see
and while having done a Broadway show
it's $150 to go to the theater and and
it doesn't travel the world the way
Cinema does and movies are unique in
that regard and so we knew that we were
never going to touch Steven's movie we
were never going to remake Steven's
movie and we wanted to reimagine it and
having music and dance was one uh were
two pieces of the puzzle but there was
another piece of the puzzle that I'd
like Blitz to talk about which was
really I think the secret sauce of why
this movie works so well and resonate so
well with not only the original fans of
Alice's book and and Steven's film but
also now a new generation to understand
what this Alice Walker family and her
ancestors were all about and how they
can inspire people today through Cinema
when I got the opportunity um to
interview for The Color Purple um I
remember first being very intimidating
of course it is sacred text you know the
legendary Alice Walker's brilliant pit
prize winning book Steven Spielberg
cinematic classic the Tony awardwinning
Broadway play you kind of go uh that
can't be me you know just because of
just how high the bar is so I was quite
nervous about it but um I went back I
read Alice Walker's book again and I
found exactly what I was looking for
first page first line dear God I'm 14
years old and I remember going wait hold
up any one who can write letters to God
must have an imagination a sprawling
imagination and that's kind of became
the lean in anything cely could imagine
we gave her uh Fantasia I know you
played cely on Broadway I was fortunate
enough to see it um but my understanding
is you were hesitant to commit to the
film yes I
was when Blitz called me and said I'm
giving celan
imagination I said I'm in they didn't
give cel imagination on Broadway so it
left the audience and me trying to
figure out how she processed through all
of that stuff I had just started
traumatic therapy traumatic therapy is
where they dig into your childhood and
tap into things that you either
forgotten or you went through that is
hindering you from your adulthood and I
love shout out to my life coach Dr Anita
Phillips but I had to stop doing therapy
with her and do therapy with sely m I
realized that sely was not the girl that
I was I remembered her on Broadway she
was brilliant I got to experience
something different with her this time
was it easy
no but I had to do the work and because
of sely through this movie I was healed
that's my
part uh taji you you're you're so
talented and I think we all knew that
you're incredibly talented and and that
you could sing but you know playing
someone like sh Avery is is is like a
whole new side of you what was she as
joyous to play as she is to watch oh
absolutely um yeah she was challenging
though very very challenging I had to
overcome of fear um but that's how I
pick my roles if they don't scare the
hell out of me then I can't service it
because if I have to if there is a fear
that I need to overcome then I'm going
to be transformed if I'm transformed the
audience has to transform with me
Danielle you also did the play on
Broadway where you received a Tony
nomination
um uh how were you asked to sort of
repre the role I I I feel like it might
have come from Oprah herself but I I
don't know if that's true or not I hear
that Scott Sanders is doing this version
and I was texting him trying to get in
there and then after a few more months I
get the call from Miss Oprah Winfrey
they did shockingly surprise me and um
she passed the Baton and I tell you it's
crazy because there are huge shoes to
feel but I'm so grateful for her because
I believe she let me and along with
blitz be my own cobbler and create my
own shoe in my own path so I'm very very
grateful for all of the months of you
know trying and and hoping and wishing
and getting to the place that we are now
Cory I I I understand when you and uh
Danielle attended juliard it was like a
class of 18 like it was a small class so
what was it like I mean I guess the
chemistry and the shorthand was already
there between the two of you there's a
lot of history there yeah and it and it
made it
um uh fun it made it easy but it's a joy
to work opposite Danielle because I mean
I I've been watching it for years but to
find finally let the world see what
she's capable of is um I'm just so happy
for you every every time I think
about what I love is Danielle's ability
to
create this moment for herself I I I
feel like you knew exactly what you
wanted when you came up to me and you
were like yeah I don't think sopia
opened the door like that you know I
think she'll kick it in I was like Go
full it but I really appreciated all the
Beats of Storytelling and this is also
kudos to all of you because a musical is
a very difficult medium right you're
telling the story through narrative work
but you're also telling the story
through these musical numbers so they
all have to have an arc and the way you
all handle your arcs is just
unbelievable like the storytelling the
you with the photograph right that's
storytelling right and then when you
throw it in the water I mean it's all
story and so again I'm still in awe but
BL I mean you gave us permission yeah
and taji talked so lovely about this in
other interviews you gave us permission
to do those things that does not always
happen and thank God for that like I I
and I love what you talk about like
really bringing like people together and
and making sure the spirit
gel you know what I mean so thank you
for giving us permission to bring what
we know we could to these characters and
not getting in the way of that and also
thank you for taking good care of us
yeah it was like a father figure on set
so thank you for
that kudos to you for that that's hard
especially doing the work that we were
doing blood work tapping into our
ancestors being on some sets where they
were still slave houses we felt that we
carried that when you got nose and you
didn't tell us you got nose you believed
in all of us when they when most didn't
believe in us so thank you for that
Blitz salute you yeah thank you and I
just want to say to you
Scott cuz we talked about it early today
and it dawned on me in an interview I
was like it makes sense that music was
added to the color purple because that's
who we are yes that that's who we are as
a people we're we're musical we don't
wallow in the muck you know we've been
through a lot history shows us that and
still going through it today and we will
sing we will go to church we will dance
we will joke around so thank you because
because you started it here we are look
at this Multiverse you've
created grateful to all of you really
and this moment I do think one of the
reasons the the musical are are my
favorite version is because there's so
much more joy and and color that comes
across at the same time your characters
are dealing with some very serious
issues uh and going through some rough
times was are you the kind of actors who
take your work home for you was it ever
hard I know Taj you mentioned it could
be hard especially in those early scenes
well I had to learn early on how to
leave it on a sa cuz I was a mother and
early in my career and so you know you
you come home and and it's homework and
and what am I eaten and got an iron a
uniform for tomorrow so I had I had to
teach my instrument how to turn it on
and turn it off yeah so years and years
of that it's like in between I can cry
know y cutting I be like girl so um last
[Laughter]
night Y no go no go ahead go no I was
just going to say we also have to
remember that this is a very spiritual
piece of
work what Alice Walker puts a pige is um
is there's a reason reason why that
Legacy is is as long as it is why that
lineage is as long as it is she when she
as Blitz said wrote dear God uh she gave
cely the ability to pray all of those
letters because they're letters they're
prayers and so she sely was praying for
Harpo and his healing sely was praying
for Sophia's
healing and Suge she was discovering
Suge and also praying for her healing
and her healing at the same time and so
we have to remember remember that we are
representative of our ancestors who have
prayed for our healing and who have made
this path for us to be sitting literally
on the stage right now with all of you
and and that is the true power of the
color purple and taji is right you know
it takes craft it takes technique
sometimes people think this is easy work
or familiar work but it is not what
Blitz had to ad do what what all of
these actors this entire crew had to do
this is work and and and it takes
discipline to be able to do that but we
have the prayers of our ancestors to to
allow us and lift us to give us that GI
it's a gift it it is a gift and I love
that it's opening at Christmas time and
one other thing that this this Nails I
think better than any of the other
versions is is this idea of forgiveness
he's not here I just want to give a
shout out to Coleman Domingo for very
challenging role I think you have to
find the nicest people to sometimes play
the worst people um but I can wait for
this to be shared with the world I want
to congratulate you all I want to thank
you for being a great audience spread
the word I think everyone's already
excited to see it but thank you so much
for being here thank
[Applause]
you